if Trump was currently president you
were still working with him on this part
of the world
what actions would you
take what conversations would you have
what ideas would you be working with in
order to unite the the various allies
that you mentioned in the Middle East
over this tragedy and um not let it be a
thing that divides the Middle East but
uh
make it a thing that catalyzes progress
towards peace further progress towards
Peace So I want to say one thing Lex I
have a lot of friends who are fans of
trump who are not fans of trump but one
thing I want to say with absolute
certainty is that if president Trump was
in office this never would have happened
and uh when President Trump was in
office anyone who supports Israel uh or
who wants to see you know Jewish people
not be innocen slaughtered uh he would
never have allowed that to happen it did
not happen when he was in power and I
hope people recognize that um as as
something that's that's very very true
um how I would play the ball where it
lies right now keep in mind we we
transferred the ball it was on the green
now it's almost like it's gone back you
know 150 yards and it's in a sand trap I
think the way that I would play the ball
right now is uh number one is you have
to show strength I actually think uh
President Biden's words were the right
words I see that they're moving aircraft
carriers to the region again the purpose
of having a strong military uh I believe
obviously you know if you get into a war
you want to win the war but the purpose
of a very strong military primarily is
to avoid a war um I don't know what kind
of credibility the Biden Administration
has uh to show the strength but right
now you have to um support Israel
completely you have to really um let
people in the region know that there'll
be consequences if they uh if they if
they try to escalate again we saw a
little bit of Rocket Skirmish from
leanon from Hezbollah um but again this
is the type of thing that they have to
know there'll be severe consequences if
they make this a multi-party fight and I
think sending a strong message to Iran I
think that they have to see some
consequences from this and know that
they're not going to be allowed to have
a free reign to cause instability and
that you know Iran doesn't usually fight
face to face they usually do it through
proxies um but let's just all be honest
about where this is coming from and let
them know that there will be a
consequence if they um if they instigate
these actions and again at least with
the Biden Administration they've had
contact with Iran they've been talking
with Iran uh but they've allowed Iran I
mean again the number I saw last year I
think under Trump the number was maybe
like four or five billion dollars of oil
revenue and in total I think last year
it was something like $45 billion in
Revenue this year I think it'll be even
more that's a combination of them
driving up oil prices but also allowing
uh much more sales uh you would think
that they would find a way to get them
to behave and allow them to to have this
happen or or if that's not the case then
be tough go back to being tough that's
what you have to
do